yeah there's a lot they do that's really
excellent yeah but I feel like they're
running on the momentum of Steve Jobs
maniacal vision yeah yeah there's been a
lot of apples changed or apples not the
same since since no more Steve which is
true obviously but they're also like
their momentum like how can you not like
they're insane they their trillion
dollar company now they continue to make
iPhones that look the same that they did
nine years ago like why not you know and
if people keep buying them of course
they'll probably never ever reason to
change it's just a different kind of
company now before I mean he was like
Gen generally regarded as an [ __ ]
like just a crazy yeah
whip cracking mic manager yeah just just
a nut like there's that famous thing of
him trying to use I forget what the
device was but it wasn't used it wasn't
working during one on stage yeah I
remember that and he threw it yeah he's
like it it was casual but it was
hilarious it was like it was anger to it
though
well because someone definitely got
fired like within minutes of that
happening yeah yeah and that's happened
on stage like things mess up on stage
like yeah it's gonna happen
Oh a couple years ago there was an apple
event whereas I'm pretty sure Steve is
on stage trying to get something to work
like in a demo and if you're been or
seen like an Apple event like the entire
audience of it half of the audience is
just people typing like blogging like
exactly what's going on so they're all
connected to the Internet they're live
blogging yes I Stevens like get anyone
nowhere but what look at his face this
is the thing like back that up a little
bit and give me some volume look at this
okay
got it well let experts see if he can
turn it on - yeah there's an anger they
had well you know he was like you
[ __ ] my speech after the show
he was definitely doing oh yeah yeah so
there's another event where like
something wasn't working and he's like I
need everyone in this room to turn your
Wi-Fi off so that this will work
everyone I need everyone to stop
blogging close your laptop's get off the
Wi-Fi and then this will work and it was
kind of like a a couple minutes of like
huh that's funny
maybe it's you serious and like slowly
like everyone did close that leaves like
everyone everyone get off the Wi-Fi
everyone close your computers right now
and this is gonna work what was the
issue I remember exactly it was must
been some Wireless related getting
something to load or work but that was
pretty hilarious to me I feel like if
you want things to operate at the speed
of Apple when he was alive you kind of
have to be a [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] yeah
you have to have that next level first
of all I need a vision of what you want
it to be mmm and then you need to be
insane enough to try to get people to do
that well he also was according to is
this hit right here
Oh Safari demo yes
[Applause]
it's a four-minute video but this is
yes is failing to load so everyone's
using the local Wi-Fi
yeah Wi-Fi is just getting taxis and
Wi-Fi is getting crushed
someone's at Verizon yeah yeah yeah 20
minutes later and see the demos or we
give up and I don't show you the demo
would you think everyone's hoping he'll
just like try again and they don't have
to turn it off yeah look at the end the
whole crowd is everyone the only reason
they're there is to live blog yeah all
right one last tweet because Steve's
telling me to turn the Wi-Fi off 30
minutes
with your face time now that's another
thing like FaceTime is another
proprietary thing that Apple has it's
really excellent yep and it's built into
the contacts it works perfectly
yeah yeah just everyone with an iPhone
you can do it with them just pop out
I would like that's a massive vat and
iMessage are like - the biggest reasons
people refuse to even try an Android
phone mm-hmm so I'm like all right well
clearly googles mission should be to get
iMessage on Android right like that
should be like a an apple will never let
that happen they know that they can hold
people hostage on iOS as long as they
want yeah if they can't get iMessage
anywhere else
yeah things like that iMessage FaceTime
airdrop walled garden yep
wonderful walled garden a whole video
about this whole ecosystem yeah it's
real it's a real major advantage yeah it
really is and they've got that nailed
they really do